hi everyone sal khan here from khan
academy as you might notice i am back in
the walk-in closet where uh khan academy
first started i am socially distanced
like i'm sure many of you all are and i
just wanted to give you a quick message
because i know in this time of crisis
there's a lot of anxieties about health
about the economy and the fact that
there are a billion students and you
might be one of them who are not in
school who otherwise would be and all of
us at khan academy as a not-for-profit
with a mission of providing a free
world-class education for anyone
anywhere we view it as our duty to step
up for the world during this crisis over
the last many years we've been building
resources starting in pre-k with khan
academy kids that covers math reading
writing social emotional learning and
then as you get into elementary school
with math and then we've recently
launched english and language arts then
we go through middle school and then in
high school
math we have things like s.a.t practice
that's reading writing and mathematics
and we have sciences and we have the
humanities and we even go into early
college courses and we've realized that
all of those can help bridge the gap as
we go through this crisis together
globally but we want to do more that's
why we have been doing things like
webinars and live streams for parents
and teachers around the world we have
our daily homeroom live stream that
we're doing for folks and we're just
trying to figure out anything we can do
to support you the student the teacher
the parent better i do want to remind
everyone we are a not-for-profit
organization and that means we are
supported by philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself you own khan
academy as much as i do no one is the
owner of khan academy it is a public
charity
and we were already running a deficit
before this crisis hit
but now our load on our servers is 250
percent of what it typically would be
and it's continuing to accelerate and so
our costs are going up our budget is the
budget of a large high school but we
reach a
reasonable chunk of humanity and that
chunk is getting even larger and folks
need us even more in this time of crisis
so if you find yourself to be in a
position you want to make sure that
other people have access to free
world-class education that students
teachers parents around the world are
supported as possible please think about
making a donation